if someone wants to pay $400 and your
price is$ 500 you can give them the
discount in exchange for an introduction
to three friends if you're a smaller
business owner and you start doing
business with other business owners
they're going to try and squeeze you
what you can do is say okay well I can't
out of Ethics charge you differently
than I charge someone else for the same
services but if you're willing to send
me somebody else I can lower the price
to X how does that sound and so what
happens is you actually change the terms
of sale you add another variable to the
negotiation again I'm starting with
three and I do that on purpose cuz you
might have ared to me like oh just ask
for one ask for three for $100 decrease
and if they say no they be like all
right how about too and so this gives
you a chip to negotiate with to both
close the sale and bring two more
customers in